nick swisher kind of you to be back here
in studio I'd be here every day if you
need from from Fox Sports 12 year MLB
veteran and it's good to have you back
here now when you get to the postseason
it becomes a different different level
intensity obviously and and it's such a
mental game and the pitching so much
better that you're not gonna get
somebody that's just either coming up
from triple-a somebody on short rest
yeah um you know you all you you might
get some you know I'm really sure but
like whether best guys I guess what I'm
saying is that it's so difficult to get
on base well knowing that in every 43
percent of the time every pitch in the
postseason is a stressful pitch that's
the thing that's why you don't see guys
going to a hundred and hundred and ten
pitches in the playoffs it just doesn't
happen that often because the stress
level is so high on every pitch that
it's hard to maintain that for the
entire duration of that Nick Swisher
here on the Rich Eisen show let's so
let's discuss a little bit more of this
and then turn to the ALCS the play at
first base right dirty yes yeah you know
I mean I was interested to see what JT
was gonna say about that as well you
know easyto so his team I understand
that and that's the thing is I think
Manny and Agee they kind of hugged it
out a little bit I think Manny Manny
wants to win he's here in LA
he's obviously he's playing for a couple
things he's playing for a ring he's also
playing for a major contract you know I
saw an interview with Ken Rosenthal he
was saying that you know he was
wondering you know which team was gonna
show him the love right you know where
he's going to end up so it looked kind
of dirty like if you would say to an odd
baseball fan what did you think about
that play they might be like wow that
didn't that didn't look right that kind
of felt like a high school play that
happened to me and I have first base
multiple times in high school because
you didn't get your foot off by the way
man there's a lot of room on the outside
part of that bag to be able to veer off
by the way in that situation you're out
like 99% of the time that ground ball to
the shortstop in the major leagues
you're out and Manny's not the swiftest
of guys and he even said it he's not
he's not the you know diving in the
first base type of guy that's just not
his personality so I think with Manny
Machado you have to take the good in the
bed and for me I think the good
outweighs that stuff well sure so let me
take this guess
piece by piece my first thought when I
saw it is why was angular hovering on
the base like that that's that's odd
right caught it right because there's a
first baseman you kind of say hey hit me
in the chest right right so when guys do
hit you in the chest you want to let
them know that you that you gotta
realize that oh so he's yeah I took that
to mean he's letting Machado know you're
out and I'm just letting you know I
thought that was a great throw for
Marcia a little bender across diamond
right right in the chest that's why I
want to have a major leader of 12 years
so just first blush you're like that's a
player T play by Machado when you saw it
yeah yeah I guess if you want to say it
kind of caught my attention yeah okay
then then I guess I would have to agree
with you a little bit I'll certainly
caught yellow shoes attention he called
him a dirty player yeah that was crazy
man that was instantly like afterwards
but the one thing I love about the
Milwaukee Brewers is the reason why they
are where they are right now so they've
got each other's back man they are a
team they are a unit and they have each
other that's the thing is a team that's
winning the World Series is the hardest
thing to do in the world she would take
25 to 35 different guys different
personalities different countries
different upbringing and you work
together as a team for a common goal and
that's where the Milwaukee Brewers are
succeeding right now regardless of that
loss last night as devastating as it was
I expect them to come back tonight with
fire and vengeance and bring everything
they have now do I think they might win
that ballgame I mean it's still up in
the air but Clayton Kershaw does what
he's capable of doing how about that 14
hours after you lose a game like that
here comes Clayton courage that's what
I'm saying yeah these are the nights
baby when I'm so happy that I'm on this
side I'm telling you what the game has
elevated so much and it's so much fun to
watch these amazing athletes perform
their craft at such a high level and
then a neat thing about a putting - a
team together for a postseason run nick
swisher here after we just chatted with
Justin Turner are the people that are
added midstream that becomes so
important Olli so yesterday you had
native Aldi do what he did from the
mound for the odd socks he was terrific
I mean he threw at one point that I saw
Brandon McCarthy oh I follow on Twitter
was
raving about a 96 mile an Carter Carter
yeah bro the fact in the world that
human being can move a baseball at that
speed in such a short distance is
unbelievable man so it just goes to show
you you just wait man and see where
these athletes are in the next 3-4 years
and what they're doing we're gonna our
minds are gonna be blown for sure so
this is you think that we're gonna see
more and more people spin a spin of
fastball I just think now power is the
name of the game
they even had you know they drive line
throwing like remember like how all we
wanted to do was hit home runs and play
home run derby when we were kids yeah
all these kids want to do is crow hop
and throw it 110 115 miles an hour it's
it's unbelievable where the athlete is
going to and then the the go-ahead run
Steve Pearce and wasn't even awful Lefty
why he smoked that one off the foul pole
off a righty and it was 3 2 and then the
dam broke with a grand slam home run but
yeah obviously the nail on the coffin at
that point but just look at where we are
right now in the postseason we're not
talking about the headliners we're not
talking about the major all starts
having the biggest impact we're talking
about the role players that you know the
Eric Kratz is the Arcia is the Steve
Pearce is the Steve Pearce is like to
see these guys step up in the moment
right now and and and to be shiny is
amazing because Orlando Arcia got sent
down to the minor leagues twice this
year and for him to come up he had three
home runs in the regular season he got
three home runs in the postseason
amazing to see him shine the way he is
right now man this is what the post
season is all about these are the
stories that you tell for years and
years to come and it's so awesome to see
it man because it's not always the best
players to get the job done for you in
the post see so the Houston Astros and
the Red Sox four games left in this
series we'll see if they even have to
play all four games how do you see it
playing out from your neck so yeah you
know I hope it I hope it goes seven
obviously every series from now on man
baseball season is almost over I know I
mean obviously it's a major love of mine
and I'd love watching the game I love
learning the game but who wins do you
think in my mind I feel like the Houston
Astros are still the team to beat I
understand that that was a huge win last
night by Boston and I also feel like
Alex Bregman maybe gave the Boston Red
Sox a little bit of
room talk a little bit of wallpaper when
he put those instagrams up on Ivaldi
when he was watching his all his tape so
I think that really means something when
they see something like man did you see
this cuz let's be honest in a locked
room it's all cellphones right you know
everybody's on their cell phones with
you know doing whatever so it's
definitely very noticed and it obviously
got taken down real quick I laughed man
I thought it was awesome because I love
Alex Bregman swag I love what he's doing
I feel like he's not only talking about
it but he's backing it up man and we're
gonna do it both you can do whatever you
want there walking him he's they're
really not giving him much to hit and
we're seeing that there young girl
sitting right behind him so it's so the
amazing thing is swish is that I'm of
the same mindset of you is that the
astros of the Astros and right offending
champs for a reason yeah and they've got
two more at home right man I think that
they've got the stones to go pull one
off in Fenway Park but while I keep
having this mindset the Red Sox keep
winning games yeah I mean they've done
it well it's crazy at all your long they
keep winning games so maybe they just
keep winning games till they send the
[Music]
paper there's nothing the Houston Astros
can't do I mean they they dominate in
every aspect of the game right until you
play the game and last night I think we
saw that and I think it just goes to
show you how important every pitch is in
the postseason so I think right now I
still feel like in my in my poll when we
started this at the begin of the month I
had the Houston Astros in the Milwaukee
Brewers so I still have two teams in it
which is nice so you're gonna still
stick with that but also not you know
what I don't know I feel like after last
night I mean I feel like that was a huge
momentum shift for the big blue for the
Dodgers I'm right back and they're in
Harris later and I'm right I am such a
fan of Clayton Kershaw and not only what
he's done for the game of baseball but
what he's done for Los Angeles what he's
done for the Dodgers the organization
he's a homegrown kid yeah to see him
having the success that he's had and
even though he had a little hiccup in
that last start I expect him to come out
and do the job tonight hopefully see a
masterful performance with your if your
counsel do you throw hater for a third
straight day knowing you're gonna
off-day here I mean well here's the deal
like he's racked up a ton of pitches
well this is the thing this is why I
feel like baseball managers need to know
they're guys I feel like you work all
season long and developing these
relationships with these individuals for
this moment so when I'm walking around
during batting practice and I'm going to
each and every one of my guys and I'm
saying hey Josh
how you feeling today brother you
feeling okay hey how many you got for me
you think you can get me one you see you
can get me too
right I go around oh my god then I have
an unbelievable gauge of how my guys
feel but nobody's gonna say no to that
but it doesn't matter I can look you in
the eyes and I can see that I can see
something different in you when you're
confident and when you're not confident
no kidding well I mean unless you're my
wife and you're faking I feel like you
know either way you got to have a gauge
for your guys and it's at the end of the
day - your call right so you think it'll
be Dodgers Astros again well I don't
know man
I feel like today I feel like I feel
like it could be Dodgers Astros tomorrow
I could think something different as you
later tonight yeah that's well I'll take
you something different after the game's
amazing you're the man swish thank you
bro thanks for coming in awesome bit
anytime baby you got it
that's Nick Swisher here on the Rich
Eisen show Kareem abdul-jabbar heard
about this I'm socket I love being with
you man but Kareem right now it's a guy
come on my dad used to give me with that
and Pig all the time every time I head
high he goes the sky look right from the
foul on couldn't do no I mean I was a
little kid man at that point you're just
under I still you know what I'm gonna go
home and work on that you should I feel
like I'm gonna send your video maybe I
get some tips from my mom or just to
show what we did in the in the
television maybe we only segment just
skyhook some marshmallows oh oh that
would be dope hey you know what else
would be dope man hey get on over to the
sweatshop man remember we're talking
about you coming to work out yes run
rich run thing man I'm serious browsers
jump down your sweat shop is your
makeshift gym and yes
as in my mind my trademark Jim in my
mind you know okay right I'm coming to
the nick swisher sweatshop brother I
can't wait I'm telling you
well before then whatever you're doing
now man it's working bro because you're
killing it so maybe maybe the sweatshop
not you think I'm not sure am i killing
it guys your guys men the love in this
room for you bro yeah yeah good to see
you swish good to see you've got a nick
swisher here on the rich eyes that
you're at Nick Swisher on Instagram at
your boy swish at you right swish on
Twitter but tastic Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience